No time to wait for my days, we're getting longer in this
No time to wait for my days, of all the time
Right, this is British lore
Oh wait, hold on
Dule Lover, thank you for becoming a member
I have no idea what it's like even it says I'm online yet
No it doesn't, oh this is the thing
Whenever I look back on a board, I'm like rambling to myself for a full minute
Because for some reason it doesn't bring itself up for a full minute
Even though I'm sitting here, meh meh
But when I look back on the board, and all that, it's all fine
All fine
The fine line
Right, where are we? Nope
Nope, not yet
Not playing the game yet
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon
I am your host, Ronnie Cuttles
Coming at you with a fried voice
Thank you, Dule Lover for becoming a member in case that did not register
She loves it, she loves it
On time question mark, yes I haven't been lurking in the shadows
I had to do some bit of background work
What's the background work you ask?
I put Shabby Cotton Bum's memberships live
So if you want to be a cheeky harem and get in
But she might not say your name during the stream though
You're probably better waiting on the stream in two hours time
Shabby Cotton Bum, maybe I should be a bit bigger
Cause I'm kinda talking
Well I'll just stand right here, like right over the text and everything
Why not? Why not? Why do I have to be professional?
It's shocking
Hold on, I'll actually go weave because BOOM!
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon little reeflings
What is on the agendination for week three?
Okay, let me talk you through it, okay?
So we're starting off strong with the ASMR stream
At the usual time
And then after two hours I will go offline and have a 15 minute pause
Because we're going to be doing our first membership watch along
Which is none other than the first Transformers movie
With Sam Witwicky and Bumblebee
Sweet little Bumblebee, I know what he wants from me
To kill the Decepticon and stop them from ruining the planet
And then the following day, on a Tuesday for the rest of the world
We are playing Zelda Minish Cap
Now statistically this game takes roughly eight hours to finish
Whether or not it takes me eight hours, I don't know
But we will be taking a pause 15 minutes before
Because for member stream, we are going to be doing the forbidden tear list
Ooooooh, not the way you want the big yin
And I get to answer it honestly this time
Because I'm allowed to say what I want to say
If we do not finish it in the first day, which is unlikely due to the member stream
Then the rest of the day on Wednesday
Is dedicated to Zelda Minish Cap
It is the only Zelda game I have ever completed or played
I know it's shocking, hold on, wait
Whoa, it won't let me stretch out chat
Chat, you'd let me stretch
Why the frick frack diddley-dack?
Does it not let me stretch chat?
Wait, is it because I normally have you on the screen?
Oh my god, let me stretch you
Why is it locked?
Chat is locked for me, so I can't even read just properly
Brev, brev
I'm trying to explain
What am I doing? Anyway
Oh my god
Eh, you be next
Thank you for coming on member
Oh my god, is that the mascot for um
WeleuVeton Inc
I'm so sorry
Chat, her name evades me right now
From hololiveleuVeton Inc
Oh my god, why is her name not in my mouth?
Purple, with the most adorable little sea ears
Oh my goodness
Anyway
Um, we are going to do old school runescape on Thursday
Oh, and now my chat's broken completely
Oh, thanks OBS
No, really, thank you
Please don't ever cook again
Oh, it finally worked
Inna, yes Inna
Oh my goodness, I don't know why chat wasn't working
Chat, yeah
Well, it's fixed, I can actually read chat now
Inna, yes Inna
In my hole, thank you
Um, let's see
So then we're going to do old school runescape
However, check it
I'm doing my first ever one-on-one collab with WeleuVeton Inc
And guess what?
It's with Mercy
I should have picked any kind of yandere
But I got Mercy
And we're going to be playing Goose Game
We're going to be playing it at her time
So we're only going to do a little bit of runescape
But if I can get a couple of levels in, I will take it
Um, so a couple hours of runescape and blabbing away
And then I will go offline for a few hours to recharge
Because I want to give Mercy my all
She's not ready for the rotism, your honor
Memberships are showing up to me on mobile
Thank you, Omar and Simpson
It still doesn't display properly
Even though I have the full chat up
Memberships are showing up for me on YouTube mobile
For a sheebie cotton bum, they better be
Because we are redirecting into her
If you didn't know, sheebie has posted pictures of herself
In a self-made cosplay of sheebie
Yep, that's a full sentence
Let me check them out by discovering the alternative twiers
If you don't know what the alternative twiers are
Feel free to check out who the accounts are following
But yes, at Mercy's usual stream time
I wanted to make the collab super easy for her
So I am going to have to rest and snort
Some...
Shouldn't have said that
I'm going to be taking lots of cola
Okay, I'm going to be slurping my cola for any caffeination
Because I'm probably going to be a wee bit
I'm going to start lagging a little bit there
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Ain't I meant for you either
You don't have to give me money to tell me this
You just realise that, Omar
You don't have to give me money to type things in chat
Scotland forever
Yes, erm...
Well, I was originally going to do a heart rate monitor this stream
Count up for the life of me, find it
I bought a new heart rate monitor
Because my other one was bust
Erm, and it's already gone
So I think I'm about to purchase the third one
Lucky me
Erm, I'll probably...
If I send a cure package to the girls
Like, for Donothons, me just looking in my...
Others have cute mascots
We have a cute Scottish girl
What?
Wait
Did Brian talk?
Did Brian say...
No, did Brian say anything there?
Oh shit, I didn't see that
Aren't...
Others have cute mascots
We have a cute Scottish...
Girl
Thank you for the five iron reaper
I appreciate it
Oh, I never heard that
Sorry, I have my headset muted
Because I have the freaking game sound in the background
It's so loud
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Can't wait to see Strone as the imposter in this game
Wait, what?
No, wait
We're playing Nero
We're playing a game called Untitled Kiss Game
Erm
If you didn't see
AC actually revealed that she's playing with Emmy
On a game called Don't Starve
And I'm like, jeez, that's a bit brutal
That's exactly AC's lore
Because she had to hunt for her food
So, rather curious
Rather curious, aren't they?
Erm
What else? Elden...
Yes, Elden Ring the DLC
Elden Ring the DLC, okay?
It launches on Friday
I'm like 99% sure
Erm
Even if it doesn't come out by the time we start playing
We have a lot of areas to clear anyway
And I am under the impression
We have to perish the enemy
That's at the top of this elevator
In that graveyard
Unironically, Ryan Goslin was the one
That vanquished him
Because I couldn't do it, I kept getting attacked
So the refland's on a freaking debuff
Like a severe debuff
Whilst I was running away from this boss
All came flying in
And I'm like 99% sure that was a Ryan Goslin kill that one
Erm
I do say shortcaller
Now, I do have a shortcaller
We're gonna test it out at the start of stream
If I can handle it
I will permit my reflings to zap me
Every time I cause us to die
Erm, I will try and keep the heart rate monitor too
Just so you can see how freaking messed up I get
Whenever we get near an enemy
Now
I need you to open your eyeballs for me, okay?
Because members' ASMR stream starts one hour earlier
Than my usual start time
The reason for that is
Imi, Azura, Mercy, Strawny
Are doing a four man uno collab
So that I can't get away from Mercy this week
I'm already entangled in her snare, you know
Erm, and then
So that's two streams that day
Yeah
Erm
And then and then and then
Sorry, I did apologize for your head
I didn't get a good sleep last night
Again
Erm
I'm getting very tired
Actually, I'll tell you something really bad
So I had to take sleep medicine the other day
But whenever I take sleep medicine
I have problems going number two, okay?
And then I hurt my butt going number two
So if there's anyone that wants to help kiss it better
And then Elden Ring part two
We again will have a full endurance on that
I am literally weaving so much content in between this as well
Because I'm also starting up my thank you series
My one ASMR video pair 1000 views thank you series
I am absolutely delighted
And exhausted to learn that I
My scheduled uploaded ASMR for 1000 subs
I've already reached 7000
Which means the debt of six is still to be paid
Erm
I'm very thankful
But oh man I'm tired
Erm
After this stream today
I'm actually going to record three
Collab ASMR's from my side
Because three girls have given me their side
Erm
So I need to edit that
Unending ASMR's
Back to back to back
Erm
There's so many replays now
I know I'm busy
My mum is very busy
Erm
If you didn't know
AC's meme ASMR has gone live
It is sniffing ASMR
If you like that trigger
Mercy's ASMR has like
I got a fucking cat here in my mouth all the time
Erm
Yeah you really do get used to it when you get cats honestly
You're just like oh that's just another part of the video
Erm
Mercy has released Yandere ASMR
Please if you absolutely despise the meme ASMR's
I got them to create
Well guess who fucking created them for them
Me
So if you hate them
Don't be like
Mmm
This video is stinky
Be like
Mmm
Strongly stinky
Because she came up with a concept
Okay
So don't
If you didn't like it don't worry
It's not like it's the only ASMR video
They're ever going to produce for free on YouTube
Like fucking relax
For one
Erm
Haha
I'm sorry
I'm literally fighting imaginary people
One person has said that at all
I know for a fact no one has said that
And I'm like already swinging on behalf of the girls
Like don't say nothing about my girls okay
Erm
But yes
Mercy's ASMR actually I was influenced by
Well
So
I had already created this over a year ago
And I think this was before the creator of Yandere Sim
Got outed for all of his
Erm
I'm 32
You have so much power over me tweets
Or whatever the tweet was
I can't remember the ins and outs of it
Erm
But
I
If you didn't know
In Yandere Sim
There's a mechanic
Where in order to lower your craziness levels
You need to laugh
You need to laugh very loud and very startling
And if anyone is around you while you laugh
It alerts them
And I was like
How did I do that for Mercy
So
I did an intro
Setting up the plot
She comes and finds you type thing
And then she laughs like a maniac
Ear to ear in the mic
And I absolutely love it
I absolutely love it
But I think that's cause I knew about
I've never actually played Yandere Sim but
Yeah
Preemptive defense is a good strategy
Literally just smashing people's skulls in
No one has said a thing to me
But the rage has already taken over
Erm
The only discord group with speedrun pan records
Honestly
Also
And
Oh did Emi release it?
So
I went the complete meme route for Emi
But Emi isn't quite with me
On the same page
Which is fine
It's completely fine
She has complete control
So I was like
Upload it if you want it
Don't
Oh wait she did upload it
Okay
So she kept the thumbnail the same
I wasn't gonna like it
Okay okay okay
So she's called the video
Alleyway Tingle Dealer
Sells you completely legal tingles ASMR
That's good title
I like that title
My title was
VTuber Sells you
Tingles in an alleyway
I think or something like that
We did have to
The artist at the time drew AC
Emi
Sorry they're twins
Drew Emi
Not Pattan
So we had to put a little
Sutton Sutton over
I loved the 30 minute Japanese one
I'm glad you enjoyed it
That is basically
What unscripted
ASMR
Turns it into
If I don't have a script
I will yap my head off
So Emi also has her meme ASMR
Now that she's monetised
Which is fan-tiddly-astic
The next
Meme ASMR is Shibi
Which I'm actually gonna ask her permission
To do it once
Once your monetisation stream
I know professional streamer by the way
Has finished
My dear Shibi
Would you like me to upload and
Pub
Is it publish?
No
Like upload and
Put live your
Meme ASMR
You guys are gonna freaking love the plot
I came up with Shibi
Shibi's plot was so unique
I had to go away and record folly sounds
Which is rare for me
Because I have a massive bank
Of sounds that I can
Come from
It was great
You were loving the ear mass
Oh you like the 7 girl collab
Oh yeah
You like 7 of us being together
7 whole neckos
Well if you're excited for that
There's another
Next week
There's another 7 man collab
Ohhh
I'm gonna have to edit it
The work never ends
I don't know what you're saying
Anonymous
I loved ASMR you did with DTW
And the rest
Oh thank you
It was so hard to put together
You know she's such a busy person
I was so excited to see this one
Oh I'm glad you like it
Thank you for the tip Anonymous
Yes
7 man
No 7 person collab
With another girl
VA
Surprise surprise
You've already guessed what channel it's going on
There's no way in heck you don't know who it is
And then after that
For next week
There's another 7 man collab
I need to put together
The work never ends
But the work is good
It's like that good kind of stress
Wait I'm gonna need confirmation
Right think of one VA
That I talk to all the time
And burst in this chat all the time
Thank
That's who's next
And then
The next one after that
I actually did a watch along of us
But
Because I have the artwork so I can edit it
But then the fourth
7 man collab
I'm waiting on this animator
To animate the artwork
And the worst part is
Well actually
It's not the worst part
The animator that I usually use
Are like
Oh I've just had a wedding
And I'm like
Oh my god congrats
Meanwhile
My stuff has been
Unedited
And the deadline has slipped
Almost 2 weeks now
And I'm like congrats on your wedding
But your honeymoon phase is over
Please get off of her
And let her have some rest
Okay
And do my work
Thanks I paid you for this
So can you just do it
That'd be great
Because
I'm currently fricking
Waiting on
Oh mama yunya
What's so proud
No not mimosa
No I do have a collab with mimosa
But that's a one on one collab
I'm jumping on her
I said mimosa you're mine
There's actually another member
Of yunmi plus as a 3dio
I need to write the plot
And send it to her
And another piece of work
That I have to do
By the way
And shibi has
Finally got a new short
Pro shibi only has two shorts
She finally has a third
And all of harem are
Welcome
Who is that shleg
Yeah that shleg
Harem
Is
A
Harem is
Very thankful towards strony
Because strony gave shibi
The script of praise
So the reason why you hear shibi
Praise you
In that short
Is because of strony
So all of harem
Please say
Thank you strony
You're welcome
Little harem
I'm looking after you
Not only did I get her
To say a short
Where you discussed her
But also
Hi lots
Oh my god
Is that the real sin
Sin star
I still need to
Message you
About rearranging
That
A
Collab
Because
My dad
Is coming home
In July
So
My
My dad's coming home
Our father-in-law
Oh do you want to meet
Your dad-in-law
I'm not getting him
To come on stream
Because he'll be like
Hi reeflings
Hi full legal name
And address
So he's not coming on stream
No having it
But yes
My dad
Is
Coming home
For two weeks
Oh my god
I can't believe
Her dad is coming home
Yes all of her dad
Collectively is coming home
I thought
About a few stream
Ideas
Like you know how
Some folk do
Like
Oh my dad
Goes through
Like
Applications
Like reefling applications
Like
I don't know if maybe
That would be funny
Or I don't know
If people wouldn't like that
I'm going to make a video
With him
About like
Being a gamer
And like
People can ask him
Questions and stuff
Being like
Oh what is it like
Knowing that your daughter's
A full blown slag
And then he was like
Well I'm retiring next year
So it's bloody good
The house is paid off
I'm retiring next year
Like name and geese a shite
Strongly I don't know
If you watch football
But I wanted to let you know
That in the game
Germany against Scotland
We won five to one
I'm going to let Brian talk
Brian still talking
To all Scots
Sorry not sorry
Okay
Sorry
I can't hear it
Because I've muted the desktop audio
Strongly I don't know
If you watch football
But I wanted to let you know
That in the game
Germany
Against Scotland
We won five to one
You pumped us
Five to one
We kicked it off
But I wanted to let you know
That in the game
Germany
Against Scotland
We won five to one
We kicked off the
We kicked Scotland off the pitch
To all Scots
Sorry not sorry
We got pumped five to one
Didn't Germany and Brazil
Not have that?
Am I going?
Am I misremembering?
Six!
I'm going to need at least
Eight more years of content
Yeah damn
You want eight years more of content?
I feel like my voice
Will be like fully
Even if you can't bring
Your dad on stream
Make sure
He still calls you
The Radish Boys
And I'm like dad
They're called Reflans
That Reflang
Their name actually didn't change
Just the spelling
And he's like
Aye the Radish Boys
Are they looking after you?
And I'm like yes dad
The Radish Boys
Are looking after me
They always do
Like I was telling
I'm like oh
One of my meme videos
Like I got a meme video
That went a bit viral
And he was like
Oh what happened?
And what's going on in the video
And I'm like
That's for me
Not for you
Can you tell him that
A yeah video of me
ASMR whispering into a
Five hundred dollar microphone
Was because I was begging
To hold a pee pee
Can't tell him that
Nah my dad knows
He doesn't know the channel
But he knows like
Because what pays bills
Let's still pretend
I wonder if my dad sounds like me
Oh his accent's even stronger than mine
Way stronger
One day we'll get to call
We'll get him to call his Radish sons
Do you want me to get him to say that?
I could do that usually
Wait wait wait
Does your dad talk in Scots too?
We are so bad
Oh yeah no my dad's like
Got a harsher accent than me
So my mum
My mum told me not to speak in slang
But my dad does
Cause he is a
I mean he just speaks slang
But my mum doesn't
So I don't really do it
Cause is your dad single?
No
Oh my god
Are you trying to be my mum?
What is going on here?
Hold on a minute
Refling
What's going on?
That's fine by me
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Oh okay
Wait let me read that
Thank you anonymous for the tip
anonymous said
Introducing a refling to her dad
As her boyfriend
And he's sitting there all
Staring at that and it does
Not to hurt his co-
No!
My dad's like
Super nice and approachable
You don't need to be scared of my dad
Honestly
Like he'd be like
Oh are you looking after Shawnee?
And then you go
Yeah
In your voice
Cause you're like
Scared of him
And then he'll go
Is she happy?
And then you go
I think so
In your wee voice
Cause you're trembling
And then after that
Oh good that's it
My dad
Me and my dad
Are on the same page where
As long as my dad's happy
I'm happy
As long as I'm happy
My dad's happy
It's nice
It's super
Super duper simple
Like that
It's just
Nice
It's nice to do that
Reflings are happy
I'm happy
If
Reflings are
Wait did I say the same thing today?
I'm happy
Refling happy
Yes like this
I think she's happy
She cusses me out regularly
With a smile on her face
Oh that's terrible
What is the Scottish shotgun
And how's it different?
I don't know
There's haggies in your face
Instead of pellets
Papastrone looks like
The dad from How to Train Your Dragon
Wait hold on
Let me
How to train your dragon
That exhibition
No
My dad doesn't
No he doesn't have beard
No beard
All the way
He doesn't have beard
But he has
Not stubble
All the way
He
Want to
Actually I'll tell you
This is really funny
One time
My dad tried to grow a beard
And I was mortified
I was like
Oh
No
It's my mom's single
You're teasing me
Refling
How do you think your dad would respond
If
Refling said
Your daughter calls me daddy too
Would I call you daddy?
I wouldn't think I'd call you daddy
Like
In my accent
Daddy's pretty
Jarring and cringe
Like
Oh yeah I like that daddy
Mmm yeah
Like no
Do you want me to tell him
Like
Oh dad by the way
The refling's call me mummy
I don't think he's going to get it
If I explain it
Oh my god
I don't think he's going to get it
I think he's going to be like
What
Oh I don't think he's going to
Confend that
That would be amazing
Oh yeah daddy
Give me your space
Hey sausage
Literally no
It doesn't work
You been like
Oh you been like
I think every VTuber calls you mummy now
I have to admit
It is an absolute cheat code
Code
If any VTuber is like
You know
Code name mummy
I'm like
Oh I'm cool with you
Hearing you say mummy or daddy in your accent sounds
Hot a f
Anonymous
Wah
Hearing you say
Mummy or daddy in your accent
Since hotspot
Are you sure you're not listening
With rose tinted hearing aids
Because
Mumme
Daddy
Oh yes
I'm feeling a bit
Rande
Daddy
Yeah you like that
Is that what you want
Tisker
Yeah you
No don't tisker that
That was cringe
Alright I'm just going to make sure
I'm redirecting into none other than Shibikotun Boom
I don't know how
Three of us has ended up doing feet
Related celebrations
Which is absolutely hilarious for monetization
That three of us has ended up showing our feetsies
That is hilarious
And I will not be taking any statements
Because oh my god
That's so funny
How are you
I'm fine
Uh
A channel that entered your girl
Wait
Scottish VTuber that tries
Way too hard to prove that they're like a Scottish VTuber
We don't need to know if your mum is single
Anonymous
We have the only mum
Oh that's so sweet
What the heck
I thought you were going to say something bad
Thank you anonymous
That was very sweet of you
Do you want to know a fun fact
A little behind the scenes fact
At Ville or headquarters
You guys have yet again supported the girls so much
That some money is on hold
You guys have supported the girls unanimously
So much that
PayPal, emailed
And we're like
Some of your funds are on hold
Not all of them
But
Yes
Thank you so much for the out
Outcry
No
For the outgoing
Insane support of me darlin
You have literally
You supported so much at the start
You broke the code
And now some funds are on hold
Because there's so much money coming in
It was actually a snowberry that did it
So shout out to the snowberries
You broke
A little bit of the PayPal
Holy shit
Did you hear my cats
Fucking I was playing with Gimli
Before I started
Stream
I wish he was going mental again
And I think I warmed her up too much
Get supported
Nero
Imagine thinking
That listening to Strowney
Saying mommy and daddy and I think
Accent isn't hot
That would drive
That would be crazy
Well, I get real close to you
I'm looking in your eyes
Is that what you should be saying?
Oh my god
Do you know those convention
Signs
Those VTuber conventions
Where they like hold a sign
And it's like five dollars to get stood on
Bro
50 cent for me to smash
My arse on your face
How about that
One cent for me
A whispered daddy in your ear
How about that?
Okay
We're gonna do a thing
At this VTuber convention
Called undercutting the market
You offer your goods
At an unbelievably discounted price
Now I know undercutting
Normally implies
There's going to be a raise later on
We ain't raising none of the prices
The prices you see
Are the prices you get
Pills out 20 bucks
Take all my change
That's a steal
Shawnee really undercutting the market now
I'm like 99% sure
I saw a cosplayer meme
And she genuinely had a sign
That said like five dollars
To be stepped on
And she was like
I made like four hundred dollars
In a day type thing
I'm like
So many different
So I guess for that much
We are getting married
With 50 children
Michi chunky bird
Thank you for the
Is that Poland?
I don't know what that is
Pozka?
So I guess for that much
We're getting married
With 50 children
Nah, no children
Did you see Azura's alternative artwork?
She did break all
What?
Azura did what?
I didn't know she was down like that
I was like
She drew that of her own
She drew that
Yes
Azura's an artist
If you didn't know
Literally all the girls have some sort of
Drawing
History
Background
KFP Spidey
Again with the five gifted
Congrats to those who caught it with your
Face
In your face
Oh my god we need to play Kung Fu Kiosk again
But I'm so bad at it
Tornado
Your doodles are so cute
Oh no
I don't know how to draw
Actually I could show
Oh I should have shown it on the
Handcam stream
I tried to learn to draw
And I was consistent for like
Five days before work
Just got far too much
I couldn't keep up with work naturally
And the only thing
I was wanting to draw
Was the girls
So I have like
Terrible pictures of me drawing the girls
Like way back a couple of months ago now
Sadly life got in the way
But I actually do genuinely think
If I ever hit
The Jenga with the five gifted
Memberships
Thank you
Congrats to those who caught it with your
Face
In your face
Sorry
I'm really
If you didn't know
There's a character called
Candy Roll in Kung Fu Kiosk
Her and Sweet and Sour
Were my favourite characters
And when my voice gets squeaky
Internally
Not externally
But internally
Because of the
You hear yourself differently
From out loud
I sound like
Candy Roll
When I get really high pitched
And
I know all her voice lines
Was it
Echo Lillia
When you repeat
What you've heard
And she's like
Kits my candy ass
And I just love her
I love her so much
She's just like
Ten out of ten characters
Oh my god
Gentoo Roller Skates confirmed
Sorry
Some sort of
Girl on Roller Skates
I don't care
Bimbo!
Oh my god
We don't have a Bimbo
Wait
What would the Bimbo be?
Maybe like a Bimbo
That lures your expectations
And then does something
Zenil Warrior
Thank you for coming
A member
Roller Skates
A Bimbo maid
I would need something
A bit more than a maid
I feel like a maid is very default
I don't know
A maid
A Bimbo maid
That is quite nice though
Bimbo maid is cute
Because then she can
Spill stuff on you
All the time
And then before you know
Bimbo
Possum
A possum
Muds
Remove this man's testicles
Possum
As in the thing in the
That goes
Anonymous
I'm so conflicted about who you're
Who is my favourite in violour
Please hypnotise me
Please hypnotise me to stay loyal to you mummy
Keep that thought in mind
Not for what you think
Because next week
We may or may not be rating
A very unique audio roleplay
Paul Lott
That involves me
And the girls
Maybe that kind of script
Perhaps sea queen script
Might solidify
Who your choice is at the allure
I am not a jealous mother
I assure you
I wish to share all
All the goodness
All the spice
I have clear ideas
A possum are kind of cute
A masochistic maid is
Metta
But it never goes out of the meta
I was debating on when to get membership
And then I decided
If it's not on the day
Strongly offers
50 cent butt smashes
What day will it be
Honestly do you think conventions
Would let us get away with that
Like obviously I'll be wearing a mask
And I'll have a little wig
So my hair is the same
But like
I feel like no one can stop
You're like
Oh what you gonna do
A reefling lies down on the floor
And I quickly butt bash him
And then get back up again
Like is that kickable to get out of the corner
I feel like that's like such a baby thing
Like oops
I tripped and landed on my reeflings face
Oh no
Nah that'd be amazing
Depends I guess
Because it'd be really weird
Messaging the convention and being like
Hey
Am I allowed to
Fall on the faces
Of reeflings
Question mark
Am I allowed
Well if they allowed stepping
Because then you can start to argue
Like oh but you allow other
VTubers to step on them
Did you know that is also
Bexley bestifying
So why is it
When I trip and fall on a reeflings face
With my
My arms
That's unacceptable
But if I step on them
That's acceptable
Oh my god convention
Talk about having double sided
Is it because I'm Scottish
Convention
You can't do that
You can't show that you
Believe in the British Isles
Sorry the
You need Kingdom over Scotland
Oh my god convention
You don't believe in the independence of
Scotland
Convention
You can't say that stuff at
Low
Yeah anyway
Yeah albalfobia
Oh my god exactly
Sends like asking for trouble
Well good thing my name's
Johnny because we're making it double
That's right me I was
The name
Sorry I was kidding
Going on a
Team rockets
Blasting off again
Oh wait that's not what they sound like
That sounded like cream
Please be careful not to fall
What
What's
As
Team rockets blasting off again
It's kinda there it's kinda there
Yeah yeah
Convention what do you mean
So there's a possibility
In a certain timeline that
I may or may not
Be able to make it to our convention
I would love to do that
But the only problem is
We have a bomb
And I'd actually need to hire
A bodyguard
Two bodyguards or one bodyguard
Bro I'm gonna be so embarrassed
Messaging security is like
A private security comment being like
Hey I basically need
Two security persons
To follow me around a convention
Is that fine
Like for bodyguard
Well I feel like the reeflings would bodyguard me pretty much
So like any shitters would like
You know get eaten up
I thought this
Thumbnail said backshot
Bro you've been on the patreon a lot too much
Okay that bodyguard
All me three four
Four is quite a lot
It's because you're Scottish
Nearly
Nearly even
United with the UK
I've spotted no I can't read that
Five might be a good number
Five little reeflings
Yeah paychecks a paycheck
Literally
The bodyguards just watching me
Like sit on everyone's face
Being like what have I been hired for
I thought it was a convention
For like weebs or something
Like not understanding this like for retubers
We'd probably get weirder requests
Eh plausible
True blood reeflings would be natural bodyguards
I think you'd have to hire professional security
Yeah no that's not the planet
A sniper too
Steady I'm not trying to take anyone's heats off
Okay and what is this
France when Star Wars got released
Did you know
That in France when Star Wars got released
Was the last public beheading
What if they are also reeflings
The bodyguards
I don't think bodyguards with a full time job
Have enough time to
Listen to me Japanese
About anything and everything that comes to my head
What yeah it's true
The year that Star Wars came out
Which is
What
Year did first Star Wars
Was the last year there was a public
Execution in France
And also just happens to be the year
That Star Wars first came out
The evening
I've been at home
I have a full time job
I can hear you yapping and so why not
How though
Aren't you getting distracted at work
Can I give you a bone bone at work
When we do the ASMR stream please
The thought I have that kind of power
It's too much power
Unlimited power
Speaking of Star Wars
I was freaked me out that scene
You have done that to me at work
Yeah stop you're gonna give me an ego
It's like one of my favourite friggin concepts
Oh my god should I write a joystick
About doing it at work
And being subtle
No I don't want you to get fired
I don't want to encourage such behaviours
That you didn't get fired
As much as you may despise
Work as a whole
It's good for routine for the brain
It's good for socialisation
It's good for keeping you active
And the neurons firing
Maybe capitalism won a little bit there
But maybe reduce it to a 4 day work week
4 day work week and not putting up to 10 hours
Cause that's outrageous
And then
For those who choose to not
Those who work on Friday, Saturday, Sunday
Get a cheeky bit of overtime as well
Cause that's not common
In all countries
Anyway before the tinfoil
Hat goes back on
It's been 44 minutes already
Guys why didn't you tell me to start the game
Are you squidding me right now
Sheepy goes live
And tea mountains
And hour and five
Showing her thighs and feet
I have taken so long and been so distracted
Right let's turn on this desktop audio
So you guys can hear what I hear
And let me turn off my background theme
This is what I hear in buckshot
Okay we're just going to jump into it
Hopefully that's not too loud
Testing
No that's too loud
Let's get my schedule off stream
Schedules we're very thankful
It's been 45 minutes, start the game
Oh now you tell me
I might have to put brightness up
I noticed that in my Crash Bandicoot stream
The brightness was so not bright
But on my screens it was bright
Hold on hydration
V-B-N-Y
V-N-N-Four
Hold the scape tag
Oh
Oh my god we're Germans
Germans like to rave
Abandoned buildings for some reason
Can I get a light mate
You got any hint on ya
You got wee baggie on ya
No right we'll just keep going then
Please sign the waiver
What's my name
Oh my god my name is
That's me
That's you
Dealer
One live round
Two blanks
I insert the shells
In an unknown order
Oh my god this back
Like the faded background music
Shotgun
Shooting yourself with a blank
Skips the dealer's turn
If there's two blanks
I shoot myself
Okay, okay, okay
Statistically we're now at 50-50
We're at 50-50
I'd rather give it to him
Shooting yourself
No I want to shoot him
I shoot the dealer
50-50
I'm sorry mate
Oh no
He's gonna sh
A defibrillator
Careful now
Defit a live
Three rounds
Two blanks
Odds are what
They entered the chamber
In a hidden sequence
Free live
I want to shoot
Sorry, three live, two blank
Okay, now it's 50-50
Two live, two blank
Okay, okay, that's good
That's good because now it's two live
One blank, okay
I am shit at this game
You're lucky I left you with a charge
Get up and on
The night is young wait, do you want this?
Okay
Do I need to turn the brightness up
On stream?
Bruh
The game
Is it bright enough for you guys?
Sorry, I'm gonna read chat
No it's good, it's good, okay thank you
I don't know why but Crash Bandicoot was so dark
Wait, is he the one that read me then?
Welcome back
Hi
I thought this game took like 20 minutes to
One live round
Two blanks, okay
The odds are in my favor for a blank
So I'm gonna
Okay, okay, safe
And then again the 50
Surely I wouldn't lose the 50-50
The second time around
Are you serious?
What the heck, I thought this was an easy game
Careful now
Oh, goodness me
Right, three lives, two blanks
I used up all my luck
On my daughters, that's what's happened
Right, three lives, shoot the dealer
Okay, the game is feeling kind
Because there's now two live and one blank
The game is trying to let me win now
I'm just gonna keep shooting
Okay, okay, we did it
We did it, we did it
See, I do not gamble
I have absolutely no interest in gambling
And on the way to one replay
You did it
Let's go
Let's make this a little more
Interesting
Sorry, I'm getting comfy on my chair
I'm sitting on my toes
Two items each
More items before
Every load, every load
This is my kind of game
Oh, sheebie
You didn't tell me you were a part of this game
Sheebie
You do not
Four
One live, one blank
Yes
So what do you do?
Dealer
Skips the next turn
Does that mean if I sheebie him up?
So I can just shoot both into him
And win
Yeah
And then I get to shoot again
Okay, yeah, yeah, I'm getting it
I'm getting it, I'm getting it
So we win
Take that
Okay
Now what?
Oh, I get more items every round
Okay, you should come round
Oh, beer
Meh
What was that? No, no, no, come back out
What was that? It said God
A magnifying glass
Two
Oh, it's a 50-50 again
50-50 again
What does beer do?
Racks the shotgun
EJX
Current shell
Racks the shotgun
Check the current round in the chamber
Whoa
It's a blank
So I'll shoot me
Rack equals pump
I'll pump you in a minute
Don't you worry
I don't know if that means the same
But in Scots that means I'm gonna do
Yeah
Okay
Well, I did a blank
So two to one
Okay
Oh, per dealer is going down
But I don't wish him any ill
Well, he just looks creepy
But I don't... He's taking a cigarette
You know, a cigarette
What? Cigarettes are bad for your health
Oh
Yeah
To health
Bro
He heals up and does double damage to me
You wet fart
Release me
Oh, I've lost this
I don't know what kinda
I don't know what kinda stuff
be going on
Sure, I'll take that and that
What?
Two blanks, three live
Oh, I'm not winning this one
Oh
This is such a creative game
I'll give it though, I like this
It's live
Well, you'll never guess who I'm shooting
That's so satisfying
I like how it's not too loud
I need to lower in-game volume
Or it's all good to go
Again
Okay
It's fine, all good
Should've cuffed him first
Can I do multiple items per round?
Wow, I got two blanks
The game's feeling nice to me
Right, I think I can just shoot him
Cause there's only one left and it's live
Yeah, take that
You wet fart
Okay, we're back on an even playing field
Okay, what items, what items
What a curious game
God, okay
All I'm getting is handcuffs and beer
50-50
Right
Right, I'll handcuff him
Please take these handcuffs
Oh, it's a harem
Right, eject the current shell
It's 50-50, this will change the odds
Out of 50-50
Shit!
Wait, okay, so it's live now
The odds are more likely it's a live round
Oh, we're doing it
We have probability
Okay, now it's likely
to be blank because
the odds are now one live to
two blank or three blank
Oh, I don't like this part
Okay, okay
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine
Right, and now it's again
back to being live
Unless
Put the gun down
It's not gonna change my mind
Live
No!
I'm not gonna make every blank
Aw, he knows what's inside
Very interesting
Yeah, I'm not surprised
It's a 1v1, careful now
Oh no
I don't know what
I don't even
I genuinely do not know what's
in this
There's no point in racking the shell
Is there?
Cuff him, everyone says cuff him
Right, I'll listen to the replays
Cause you guys are smart
Right, I've cuffed him
And then I'm gonna
Okay
Oh, I just ended the round
What?
Yes, I'll absolutely take that
Oh, and a ciggy
Giazawi
Whoa, the odds are very high
for a live round
Sorry, look
I'm not the smartest, right
Regain a charge, I'll have a wee puff puff pass
Yes, nicotine
No, it's not good
I actually did it
A blank, right
Okay, okay
Me
Okay, that's good to go
Okay, so now it's like
5 to 1
We're just gonna shoot
What a curious game
I'm very intrigued by this
I'm intrigued by the dev team
I'm intrigued by the graph
One reflying, and on one
Yeah
Long last, we arrive at the final showdown
No more defibrillators
No more blood transfusions
Now me and you
We are dancing on the edge of life and death
Eh
Four items each
Handcuff
Magnifying glass
I'm starting to forget about my feet going on
Eh
You know the drill
Is he gonna handcuff me?
If I handcuff him
I can double
I can double shoot
And the odds are he's gonna get shot
Okay, there you go
Okay, we're doing it
Uh
Doesn't tell you what his health actually is
But he's
So we can just double
Oh no, they're both blank, aren't they?
Ah, yeah
Wait, no
Oh no
I messed up, hold on
I'm so dumb
Yeah, okay, right
And then fresh start and two new items
What we get, what we get
Show me the money
We got beer
More handcuffs
Oh, a beer
Four live, four blank
50-50
Handcuff
That gives me two in a row
Uh
Eject one to make seven on the board
Odds our lives
Blank
Two blank remaining
Four live
Odds our shoot, shoot, shoot
Shoot, shoot, shoot
One blank
Four live
Wah
Can't give him that
Can eject again
Wait, no, wait
What did I just do? Sorry
Three live, three live
One blank, shoot
Yeah
Cuff him
Oh, could I cuff there? No, he's still cuffed
Okay, now he's uncuffed
He's gonna eject
Two live
One blank
Handcuffed though
Health revivals
Oh, no
Ah
Eject alive
Two live remaining
Son of double for two health
No
Three health total taken
Two live
Ah
This game is good
Oh, I like this game
Hold on
Okay, we got a health, we got a peak
We got two peaks, a health and a cuff
Three live, two blank
Okay
We're gonna cuff
We're gonna heal
Because we do need a cheeky bit of health
Because it is
Three live, two blank
Did we take a peak
Or did we
Wait, no, just taking a peak matter
If he's cuffed
Well, because yeah
It doesn't matter
No, it doesn't
That's what
Two blank
Oh, dear
Right, doesn't matter if he's cuffed
You can just double shoot, doesn't matter what the results are
Right, what I've already forgotten
What we're at, is it one live, two blank
Or two live, one blank
Heals, he's got two heals on the board
And he's got double son off
Now it's two live, one blank
Sugar, did you
Yeah, he's gonna shoot me
No, for two health
He's gonna shoot me for the son off
Oh, this is
My odds
Wow
Gosh
Wow, hopefully I can get some
Cigarettes
Right, cuff
Wait, why cuff?
It's two blank now
Yeah
That's why I shouldn't have cuffed
Remaining ammo, zero
They're both blank
I'm not right, I need to focus up
I need a piece of paper or something
It was a 1v1
Right, items, cuffs
Peak, peak
Oh, we've got a double son off
If we peak, we could get a double
Four to two
Four
To two
Cuff him
Let me know what's going on under the hood
Let me double up
The damage under the hood
Beautiful
This is acquire two HP damage
Oh, that was satisfying
So now we are three live
Two blank
Now it is a two in three
Oh, dear
Oh, dear, oh, dear, oh, dear
Cuff
Oh, he just released the blank
Oh, no, this can't be
This can't be
Oh, dear, I am
On life support, I believe there's
Unless that's it
I don't know
Okay
Well, I'm handcuffed, he's won
I've lost the odds game
Oh, no
Strummer bad
I'm handcuffed
Are you ready?
Yeah
Well, I can
Hopefully there's a heal
Double damage
Oh, what are these
Live, live, live, live
Five, live, three
Goodness me
Heals don't work anymore
Oh, you can't even heal anymore
Oh, that's why the game is giving me critical damage
Let's see what I'm working with
Blank
Well
Five to three
So now it's five to two
And then
We'll just check again
Okay, live
And then we'll do double damage
Unfortunately, the odds are not in our favor
But, hey-ho
So that's four to
Two
We're not gonna make it
Unless he throws
We ain't gonna make it
Oh wait, what?
Wait
Are you saying there's a chance?
If it's in the chamber, are you saying
There's a chance?
Against all odds?
What?
What did I do with it?
Oh my gosh
From the brink
What a fantastic game
Oh my goodness
Congratulations
And on shots fired
24 shells ejected
54 doors kicked
4 cigarettes smoked
2 millilitres of beer drank
Total cash
What a fantastic game
Where's any button to exit?
Wow
Double or nothing unlocked
Are these the developers?
The symbol?
By computer game
by Mike Kaluub
Nika
What a fantastic game
The visuals
The direction
Did we go again?
Did we go again? Double or nothing?
How did I do double or nothing?
Is it just start?
Just start
Start then click the pill bottle
Wow
Oh it's changed
It's changed
Because of our progress
I'll click the pill bottle
Consume pills may impair your ability to drive
But reflings I don't want you to go
Consume the double or nothing
Oh no the guy's gone
Bye strongy
What an amazing game
Please sign the waiver
Yes
Let's do it
I am blown away by this game
Sorry
I know how to spell your name
Sorry I didn't mean to misspell it
It was a genuine mistake
Double damage
Handcuff
Mobile phone
What are you?
One live to blank
A mysterious voice gives you
insight from the future
Swap the polarity
I think we'll just cuff
and double shoot
If both of the blanks happen
to be in there
Wow I have rubbish luck
That's fine
Now it's a 50-50
If I shoot a blank at him
I'm going to be
Should I go all?
Not looking
Okay rough start
Double or nothing
It was a double start
Okay
Two health already
We've just gotten started on this
He's got health up
Hydration check
Okay we can pump one out of the chamber
We can heal and we can swap
Another polarity
Wow
Interesting curious
Again with a blank
I am going to
Puff one out of the chamber
To see what the odds are
Okay now it's 50-50
So I'm going to heal up because we already know what it's going to happen
And then
We're going to saw
it off
And we're going all in on double damage
against him
Dealer
Use the phone
Right I'll use the phone
Sorry it's the phone about the current round
or the next round
Oh my god he's doing
Double damage against me
That's so bad
Right I'll do the phone my apologies
I thought the phone was like for the next round
Careful now
Careful re-flowing
Re-flowing
Wouldn't want to be dancing to death
Let's see you
What is you
Okay
Ring ring hello
Three lie four blank
The game is trying its best to help me right now
A mysterious voice
How smart
Do you think I am
Reflings to be able to
retain the information
That on the sixth shell
It's blank
How smart do you think I am
What is this a pipe bomb
Steal an item
And use it
Well
Oh no
Oh that's exactly what happened
They put adrenaline directly
into your bloodstream
What was that medicine box
I wonder what this is
I don't have it yet
There's nothing I can do
Other than cuff them
and double shoot
What
That also means the fetus isn't going to be blank
I just need to send it
Sorry I can't
No okay
So it means like these next few are live
Gotta go straight to cuff and meet
Okay
Okay I've definitely messed up this one
What is that
A medicine packet
He takes a pill
Oh I healed
Okay that's fine, cigarette or pills heal
I know
I've lost
Oh no
Who is he calling literally
Aw that's such a shame
Wait
He put the polarizing effect on
Oh no I'm gone
Sorry
Right I didn't know how the phone worked
Not that it probably would have helped
Oh by the way the fifth one's a blank
Oh thanks for that mate
Let me just add it into my fucking calculator
And have the largest IQ
And my brain goes three-sided
You know the average person who can only retain
Like freaking what
Four bits of information at a time
Like come on give me a chance game
Let me write it down, give me a wee piece of paper
And I'll write it down just like this
He kicked the hell out of this cuttlefish
Literally I'm calamari right now
By all accounts right
Let's try that again
Pump one out of the chamber
Adrenaline burst, health and double damage
Okay
Okay we can work with this
Four before
Two live, three blank
What do I do with that information
I don't know
If three blank should I shoot myself
Or should I make the odds known
If it's 50-50
Three blank, two
50-50 double damage
Let's go
Two blanks in a row
Possibly
Oh yes
Okay, okay, okay
Okay
He's gonna pump it out
Now it's back to 50-50
I'm being cuffed but I do have a blank
Yep and then one health damage on me
Unless he wants to use the polarizing effect
And let me win
But that's slightly different
Okay, okay, that's good
Let him get up, let him get up
Good shot
Are you squinting me right now
Cooper
Brian, Blasterman
Thank you for the five
Cooper and yes I will Blasterman
Okay two blank one live
I have nothing
What's that
Medicine, steal his medicine
I think I'm gonna steal his health
Prevent him from healing up
Give me that
What does it do?
Why did my head just
Two blank one live
Okay
Medicine is 50% chance one damage
And two heal
Oh wait is that
Okay we are classic 50-50
If we get this
We have won the first round of doubler nothing
Dealer
Oh that was a clean round
That was a clean round of odds
Very clean
And on wins, okay
I'm taking medicine again
Because I didn't realise I could hurt myself with it
Okay
Oh great
Fucking tiddlywink spawn
No I'm not taking that
Okay what are the rounds
Let me know
Full eight
50-50 full eight
Okay
Remove one from the chamber
Let me know my odds
4-4
3-4
3-3
6 total
4th shell live
Ray
Can I just take his fucking heal then
4 is life
6 total 4 is life
So I have to
It's most likely a blank
You know that
If 4 is live in that sequence
There are most likely 2 blanks before it
Wait
Am I an idiot
Did I not take a heal
Did I not take a cigarette
Am I being dumb
Did I not
Is your max
You can't over heal
Oh
Fuck
Fucking just shoot him
This is not gonna work well
No
Why is he doing polarizing
Meh I suck at this game
Let me go again
We've got time for another
Why is this game
Ah fuck he's suck at this shite
The only thing I'm good for sucking is willy
Not this game
Get me in that room
Right you
Again
Please sign the waiver I consent
Your gacha luck is not great
I've actually never played a gacha game
Call in a friend
Polarizing in the seat
Right I'm glad we can get a peek
Right let's try this again
It's okay
I'm gonna take a peek
What have we got
Alive
I am gonna steal
His sawn off and give him 2 damage
Now I'm aware he has a heal there
No I'm not
I'm gonna steal his heal
Fuck off
Your cigarettes are mine
Awww you can't over heal
The reeflings just told you
That mere moments ago that you can't over heal
In this game mode and what do you do
Reade it over heal
You could have had him down to 2
You could have had him on the ropes
But no no
Okay 50-50 odds
He's getting insider knowledge
Did you know
Celebrities calling the paparazzi
To tell them ahead of time
Where they're gonna
Right
3 lives
Blank
And he's gonna hurt me
Real good
3 lives 2 blank
3 lives
2 blank 3 lives
2 blank we won blank 3 lives
Boom
That's right take that you stinky stinker
No 2 lives
1 blank
Yeah I'm not surprised
I'm not surprised
That's okay
Let him get up
So now there is no blank
How can that not count
Awww
That was even again
Okay it's fine we're back
Right now
There's no blank yeah there's nothing now
Okay let's try that again
Not gonna take that
Might use that
Double or nothing double or nothing
Double that dammit
Okay 50-50
It's 50-50
The only thing I can do is call in a pow
I don't
It's 50-50
Let's give him the damage
Let's go let's brain hell
When I said brain hell
I didn't mean like wind
Literally all he
He felt was a little
Wait
Awww
Man
Alright so that's blank
Very
Interesting
What are you stealing
Give it back
Oh you can have that
Please hurt yourself with it
I'm gonna make it
I'm so bad at this game
Careful now
I'm trying to be careful but I suck
Okay
If I eject this one
This one's blank so I'm gonna shoot myself
I'm removing this one
The next one is blank
So I'm just gonna
Play it safe and do that
He is using developer luck
Remaining ammo
Oh my god you guys try to help me so much
I'm so bad I'm so sorry
Right we can now double
Double saw it off at least
Why did I get two turns in a room there
Wow
Well it's now even Steven
No it's not cause he has two health and not one
Cause I'm dumb
What is he doing
Polarizing
Okay
Hiya
Dude
So bad
Oh my goodness this is so hard
Yes please
Let me try again
Let me get up
I'm afraid
I'm very afraid
The force was a blank
Yeah that's why I shot myself with it
Sorry this must be painful
I'm so sorry
I'm not very smart
You guys didn't figure out I wasn't smart by playing connect 4 with me
In old school runescape
Anon
You know what
Yeah that's right
Call me big willy
Cause I got a big massive willy
One
Right
Let's try hard
It's time to try
Not two irons or he only got two as well
Big willy
It's a 50-50
Let's try again
If it's a 50-50
I could just win by doing this
But he can do the save to shoot me
But he can still
He can still hurt me
Cause the first one wasn't
Wait what
Oh if you shoot yourself you get to play a second turn
It's finally starting to make a little bit of sense
Health?
But I can't overheal so don't get jealous
Whoa
Why so many irons
Oh he got loads of irons too
Two life three blank
Three
Three blank
No it's 50-50
No
It's
Oh god
I can't use my brain and talk at the same time
Just let me see what it is
Please
Okay
So if I shoot myself
I get to go again
And then I get to double shotgun
Barrel you
Am I doing it?
I think I'm doing it
Why is my luck so poor
There's all life now
What does polarize do?
You could have inverted
And then sawn for the win
Wait that works backwards as well
If I know it's blank
Polarize it to change it
This must be the most painful place
Or you've ever seen
I even think we're going to be able to do it
In time for Shibi's monetization stream
Okay
I didn't realize polarizing
Swapped
The
Oh shit I did not pay attention
To how many live in
You know
If I know it's a blank use polarizing
Got it
Okay it's alive
It's alive
So I am going to
Steal your double damage
Steal his saw
Steal his double damage
If I know it's a blank
Polarize
You've already finished the game
This is infinite mode
Wait it's the same
Right he's on one health
He's gonna
Sawn a friend which is fine
He's gonna cuff me
Zadim
Oh yeah you want to
Cuff me up
Right he's healed which is fine
We're no one even Steven
What was that
Adrenaline he's healing again
Oh you could
Yes
Hello
Why would you do that
Question mark
Did you mean to do that
Okay please
Take a xp
I hear a health down health down
Aha
Oh yeah
Oh no he's done polarizing
Oh no
Ow
I don't know what it is
I don't know what's left
Oh I do know what's left
So if I blank myself
Oh polarize
Polarize you stupid women
You
Polarize
Polarize the blank
Oh my god I was so
I freaking clicked it and my brain was like
Wait a minute you were supposed to do something
Freaking polarize
Okay give me give me give me give me
Give me give me yeah give me yeah give me
Yeah blank
Right 50-50
Okay
50-50
Inspect element
Inspect element blank
Blank found
Polarize effect added
Polarizing
And then what
Shoot myself or shoot him with polarize on
Shoot him with polarize on
Man she sure is pretty
Yeah that's all I got going for me
This feature of model is adorable
Okay shoot him
We did it
I was so sorry
Shoot um right we did it
Willy wins
Big Willy wins
Imagine if this is the run I went on
And it's the one I call myself Willy on
Right
Okay let's see what we're working with baby
Rejection
Calling
Focus right
Uh
For help on big Willy 50-50 odds
Okay
He can see he can cuff and he can double damage
Maybe the phone
Can tell me if what's first
If not I'll just use the magnifying glass
That's absolutely nothing
Can you not pick like the second bullet
So I'll actually remember
Right I don't have polarizing
So I can shoot myself for free
That's one
So odds are
I can just shoot him
Nooo
Are you fucking kidding me
High odds of being
Live literally the seventh shell is blind
So and
And two bullets have been utilized
This is the third bullet
Being utilized
Right
So the odds of this one being live
Are high again
Oh no
Okay
Is that four shots now
So then five and six are live
Five is live
So
What
Does this game want from me
What does this game want from me
My odds
I know you can't rely on odds
That's just how odds work
My odds are
Astronomically
Right Willy's definitely
We can't even do it as Willy
We have to go back to our roots
Cause this clearly isn't working
It wants you to suffer
My poor Willy
My poor Willy got blown off
Right
I'm actually
I'm like do I get a piece of paper
Cause I might
These are good items
What are the odds
Give me a 50-50
We've got a 50-50
I can't overheal past two
If it's
50-50
Let me see
What's
Or eject
I might be able to
Eject 50-50
And tell me what's up
Right taking it out alive
So if we're gonna get a blank
We're gonna steal the polarizing
No it's live
I really don't have a double
Oh sugar but he has the polarizing
Well next to a blank
So if he uses polarizing
Then he's won
I think
No he can only do one damage to me this round
Okay okay
Steal the car
I don't think
That would have
Bro
Bro it's not looking good
Why is this game so hard
I just need you guys to like
Send me your gaming footage
So I just commentate over it
Cause this is getting so bad
Careful now
All I've been told this game is careful now
Yeah yeah yeah
They're both blank we know
We know they're blank
Well at least I
Have a cigarette
Right
Two live three blank
But he doesn't have a polarizing
So blank actually means
Blank in this game
I'm gonna steal his
Cigarette
No
Can I get a vase
Three blank two live
So the three blank are up ahead
So odds are
This is blank
Can I steal his health
I don't want him to heal
Yeah this is blank
It's my guess
Oh for fuck's sake I keep being greedy
Right this is blank sorry
I'm guessing but
Yeah okay odds are
Right I'm happy with that
I'm happy with that
Right we're gonna take a peek
Blank again wow
Blank again
And then the rest are live
In a room
Well unfortunately he's gonna get a lick in on me
How do I suck so badly
I'm not being funny I'm getting
Absolutely rolled
I'm getting
Just
They're making a mockery out of me
They're making an absolute mockery out of me
Does this guy even have a name
Okay phone a friend
Adrenaline
Oh he got a heal I'm gonna steal his heal
Right it's a 50-50
You need to start comboing the items
Oh I'm too dumb for that though
That's actually
An injection into
That
Adrenaline into your heart
Which basically forces it to go
Blank
I'm just shooting
So anyway I start blasting
Cause I'm unable to keep up with them
Right there we go boom
Oh wait I actually won out of just pure frustration
We won that round
Anyway start blasting
We did it we made it to round 2
Of double or nothing
I've still yet to make it to round 3
Okay let's see what we get
Cough, double
Damage, adrenaline
Not medicine
Medicine that's not really medicine
Too blind
Does he have a polarizer he does
Phone and a friend
Wow okay
Steel
Polarizer
Shoot him
Steel polarizer
Yes
Shoot him
Steel and then shoot
Okay
Then he'll shoot blank on me
Cause we know it doesn't have anything in it
And then double sawing off
Oh he's healing
Okay
So let him shoot
That's just fine cause it's blank
Oh
Forgot he can get an extra turn
If he shoots himself
I keep
I keep forgetting the mechanics
Of this dumb game
Why is it he is allowed to heal
And he's allowed to do this
And he's allowed to do that
Don't you know the video game rules
Only I'm supposed to be able to do
All the things that help me win the game
I never thought that far ahead
I never thought in the first place
That should be my sentence I don't think
Right what was that 50-50
Right at least we can heal first
Watch your enemies
Hand closed
Hordeshell
Live round that gives me nothing
Thank you don't ever speak to me again
What's in the chamber
Blank
I don't have a polarizer
So I can officially shoot myself
Bunk
Right and then
And then what
I mean that means all Tsar
It's a double
Cuff him
Okay and then what
And then
The best I can do is just guess
I'll say it from this one
So is this the third
Wow
This is why I don't gamble
I have no interest in gambling
I have no interest in playing Genshin Impact
Because it's a Gamba game
Or something like that
I actually don't know if Genshin Impact
Is a Gamba game but
Yeah
Remaining ammo
The fact you're trying to help me
And it doesn't help because I'm so dumb
It doesn't help
I'm too dumb to be helped
You guys are just going to have to send in
Your gameplay and I'll commentate over
And pretend that I'm playing
That seems like a plan
Surely
I'm not, I'm losing it
New round
Let's see what we've got
Let's see what we're working with
Two lives, three blanks
Okay, okay, okay
Oh yeah
A burner
Just show me if it's good or bad
It's good
I don't have a polariser though
Clink
And there's four in the chamber left
So let's talk to the phone
Because the bass ain't listening
Okay
That means the odds have increased
That this is a live round
So we're going to say
Funk it
And we start
Blasting
Okay, we know next is blank
But he doesn't
He doesn't have a polariser
Either
Hold on
Oh
Good or bad
We know this is blank
But we know that this is live
And now he knows it's live
And he's got a double
It's ogre
And he's cuffing me
Bro
Wait what
Now it's live
Oh my goodness
Golly
If you are like me in small brain
This game ain't for you
I've got one more in the tank
Because she's actually getting ready to go live
We've got one more
Come on
That's it, you know what
I'm getting a piece of paper out for this
I'm writing down
This freaking piece of paper
Writing on in this game
I'm going to call in
This freaking
I'm going to call in the big guns
Which is me writing on a piece of paper
To write down the odds
To write down what there is
To write down what to do
If we do not win this one
This settles it
That you guys are just far too smart for me
And you have picked the most
Our worded oh she
There possibly could be
Right
Pull out items
Magnifying glass
Health
No don't want meds
I'm not taking my meds you can't convince me
Right
What's in the chamber
Two live
Three blank
And then I'm going to do it
Like hangman on my piece of paper
So the odds are already
Not
The best
I am going
To
Seal his phone
I'm going to steal his phone
No
Yes
Yes I'm going to steal his phone
To get the intel
Fifth shelf blank
Okay so for hangman
There's now a B on the fifth
One
For blank
We are going to see what's inside
Because either way we're doing damage to this round
It's a blank so we're going to apply the polarizing effect
We're going to put B on the first
Hangman section as well
So we're polarizing to make it hurt
The dealer
Is being shot with the polarizing effect
Resulting new damage dealt to the dealer
Okay
So first one's blank
Last one's blank we now know this
That's perfectly fine
All it took was writing it down on a piece of paper
And playing hangman
I do not fully understand this game
Neither am I that's why we're playing hangman
He is now inspecting
He claims
The contents are very interesting
He shoots me
With a live round
The second position is live
We are now on a 50-50
On the contents of the gun being live
Or blank, we cannot ascertain
We can heal up
But we cannot ascertain what is inside
This truly is a 50-50
He drank a beer
What did I miss it? Two and three were live
So we know it's a blank
Wait
But none of us have a polarizer
So this round can be complete
So we need to start a new freaking round
In hangman game
Goodness gravy
All blanks
Okay
A BBL
No I didn't get a BBL but thanks for asking baby
Right
Let's play hangman over again
Let me, what is the ratio
Three live four blank
Three live
Four blank
Full of seven on hangman
One, two, three, four, five
Seven, I have adrenaline
To call in
For information
Which we're gonna do
Right
You can yoink the yoink
Right, position second shell
Blank, hangman
Second is B blank
Oh sugar I just dropped my pencil
If we handcuff
And we are going to act like
The first one is live
Okay
We are going to treat it as live
We do not know and we cannot ascertain
If that information is true or not
However we can shoot ourselves for
Okay that was a blank
We know the second is a blank
So first two are filled out Bs
That leaves two blank and three
Live on the board
We are going to shoot ourselves to give ourselves another round
Sadly
There are now
Five pieces
Remaining
And we cannot ascertain the knowledge
So we're going to treat it as alive
This truly is a 50-50
We're gonna treat it as alive cause the odds are it's alive
You know what I'm just gonna go fuck myself then
You know what
Because that's the thing with odds
That is the thing with odds
Yeah
Yeah it could literally
You can flip a coin ten times in a row
And statistically never get heads
Ten times in a row
But that's the thing with odds they are not reality
Yeah yeah
Yeah
That's right another
Sorry I'm addicted
I'm addicted I like this approach sorry
The hangman approach is quite fun
I'm addicted I can't stop right
We've got ten minutes to speak on this
Come on
Ten minutes
Oh my god come on
Please sign the waiver I will
Anything for you dealer let me do it again
Again again again again
Ah
Okay
Let's do it
Uh
Right
Let's go
Who goes there
Identify yourself
Three live
Four blank
Seven hangman
Okay
We have adrenaline
We are going to get
Intel from this adrenaline
I assume we can only use adrenaline
Once again right the intel is
The intel is
Third shell live route
Okay
Can we do double adrenaline
Hello
Double adrenaline
That's cheating
Blind shit
Oh we have a polarizer
Okay that's perfect
If we hand cuff
Or does that leave
That's two live on the board we don't know
About three live on the board we don't know
Tell you what we could do
Hand cuff
Polarize
Shit
Discard
The current unknown
Because we don't know what it is
And I don't trust it
So we're just gonna discard it
Okay we're just gonna discard it
It doesn't really matter
Okay so we can write down blank in second
So now there's two blank and two live
The odds are straight back to 50-50 again
We are going to shoot
Okay okay so now there's one blank
Remaining and two live on the board
He's gonna eject a blank
So all remaining are now live
Shit
And he's gonna do
He's gonna do three health damage in the sequence
Wait
Yeah no
Sorry sorry sorry
Then blank was the fifth there and then it's two live
Remaining now
Sorry my apologies
Two live remaining
Unfortunately he will get a lick
In on us but that's fine
That's fine
Do you feel so big brain now
No I'm cheating by playing hangman and writing it down
That's how hard this game is for me to conceptualize it
In my head
I cannot do this in an
Abstract
Concept
I don't have the ability to do this
I have to write everything down
We've got insight
We've got two insights
Fantastic
I'm not gonna do it for this round
He's got a polarizer
No he doesn't
I might as well shoot then
Shouldn't I
There's no point in using this stuff
It's a 50-50 I might as well just shoot
There's no point
I've got two phones
One for the veiler
No use the phone
No get info
But wait wait wait hold on
Hold on
What's the point in me using the phone
Right now because it's 50-50
If it's a blank
Oh wait
Yeah idiot
If it's a blank then he can't get a lick in on me
Sorry
I'm so slow
It takes me a moment to remember
The way this game plays
I'm so sorry
We are on to the second round
Okay
Okay okay okay big brain time
Big brain time
Winkles
Becoming more wrinkly in your brain
Your smooth piece of chicken breast
Brain is no magnifying
Three live three blank
Hangman of six
Okay
Insider knowledge
Yes please
Third shell
Blank
Okay
Yonkers
I would like insider knowledge
From the adrenaline burst
Okay
What are you gonna tell me
Fourth shell
Blank
Okay
Now that leaves one blank
Unknown
The odds
Is now one in four
Of the current shell
Chamber being a blank
I think I want to shoot
So anyway
I start blasting
The odds of one in four
Yeah okay that's what I like to see
Live one in four
We are going
Okay he's gonna heal up that's perfectly fine
He is gonna be able to see what's inside
And he does have a polarizer
So I'm gonna have to be cautious of that
He's gonna check it out
What do you see
Very interesting
Okay
Oh he's shooting it's alive
So the next two we know are blank
So we can blank it up to high heavens
Okay
Blank
Bonk
And then blank again
Thanks to our insider knowledge
And it worked
And blank again
Then we are going to drink the beer
To inject the second last bullet
Because we will be able to
If this is blank
Or if it's live so that was live
So that means the remaining one is blank
So we can just shoot ourselves
Bonk okay all good
All good in the hood right new round
We do
Insider
The game knows we are playing hangman
The game knows what we got
Four live four blank
Four live
Four blank
Hangman one two three
Okay I don't have enough room on the paper
One two three four five six
Seven eight sorry I need to re-write that
Because I put it at really awkward bits
Right
Let me know what's the update
Let us know what's going on here
Third shell live
Perfect
Let me know what else is going down
Obliet
I didn't realise he could do that
Yeah
I didn't know he could do that
Like thanks
Right I'm going to
Against my better judgement
I'm still going to take this
Because it's so much better and more valuable
To know what's coming up
Fifth shell live
Okay okay okay
We only don't know where two are
That leaves me to believe
So the odds are now
What
One in three that this is blank
No that's not correct
I want to shoot myself
Against my better judgement
I'm going to claim this as a blank
Because statistically it should be
Okay
We did it
Okay we have a second round now
There are
Three blank
What does this mean
Cigarettes I can't heal up
I don't think
In Minecraft
Unknown second live
I don't know
Shoot or not
Your max is HP 4
Let's have a wee quick
We'll start mull over this
Thank you
My apologies
I thought this was like you couldn't heal it
A 4 4 4
Should we get a cigarette
Smoker and gen 2
Apparently that's a really big kink
That I didn't know about
A wham and smokes a ciggy
No
I don't know what it's going to be
You know what
If I shoot myself
It's actually going to not be that bad
Okay we know this one is live
So we can shoot
A double shot
I get so excited to like
Utilize
We would have gone on to the next round
Oh we would have gone on to the next round
If I wasn't so
Freakin quick shorty
Okay
He just ejected alive
So it's live live live actually
Wait what
Oh
Thanks for letting me go to the other round
Even though I messed up I appreciate you dealer
The game must know
I'm like sweating so hard
We finally made it
To round 3
Okay
Hangman ain't got nothing on us
Medicine
Polarize
That's fine
2 live 2 blank
2 live
3 blank sorry
Sorry number
We have no insider information
We have odds which is blank
The odds
Stepulate this is a blank
So I shouldn't theory put the polarizing
On and shoot myself
We have to go with odds
We have no choice shoot the dealer with polarizer
On
So that was a blank
So now it's 2 to 50 50
Perfect and he can see what's inside
Very interesting
Live okay
The odds are now 1 live
2 blank
Wow
If I take the medicine I expire
Because my odds are not good enough
This is it
I either win this game mode
Or get it on whatever we pick
Now the odds are
This is blank
Swallow the medicine
I'll swallow it
Because you asked me to
Refling
Ah!
Forever tame because she be live with celebration
It was worth it though
I died doing what I love the most
Guzzling refling's ink
I perished doing what I love the most
Okay
So I don't feel that bad
That was so good
That was fantastic
I can 100% see us revisit in this game
In a membership stream
I don't like replaying games that I may have already done before
But thank you
So so much for that
Fantastic experience on this game
Another 10 out of 10 game
Shout out to the developer
That is like such a fun little odds game
So goofy
Incredibly entertaining
And the graphics
As well as the design
Visual design is absolutely
Beautiful
Some people might not enjoy
The poly
Looking art
Art style is the word I'm looking for
The art style
Right
We are going to redirect
Into none other
Than she be cotton bum
For her
Psycam
Membership monetization celebration
Wherever the Frick Frick didle-a-dack
Tic-tac-patty-whack-nick-nack
I am going to make sure
I am redirecting into her
But that was fantastic
In that game with me
That was so good
We will definitely hangman this game at a later date
Because
Gosh golly gee
That was just amazing
We finally started
It started to click at the end
I need to redirect into Sheepsters
Cause that didn't work properly
Thank god I checked that
Right all good in the hood
Yes thank you so so much
Reflings I will see you
You
Yes you
For an ASMR stream at the regular
Time and then 15 minutes later
I will swap all my equipment
Back over to my regular streaming equipment
And we will have a membership
Watch along of transformers
And don't be greedy
See that
Don't be a naughty refling and see that
Thank you so so much for hanging out
That was an absolutely amazing game
And
I will see you Giffy Gibbers
Pardon me as I burp my cola up
Tomorrow
My little Reflings
We will do it all over again
Say hi to Sheeby for me
Bye Reflings I love you
Say hi Sheeby